yeah look at us in the stairwell this is
gonna be classic dude yes great this is
gonna be classic our only other option
was to sit on the bed together which I
think that that is a totally erotic pod
a router pod I don't know if that's a
weird niche do you sit down I'll just
make sure this isn't focused and we're
gonna be good
we just want to make sure we get your
your hat and focus the dusty sleigh hat
yeah gasps microphones are not this
heavy what do you use France I don't
know I went on this bnh audio yeah yeah
you have like the podcast set up okay so
I just bought that oh it always included
yeah they had a yeah to Mike thing it's
not this what yeah which is a quarter
yeah I use this more like ouch for more
like a soundboard like a mini sound like
a mixer cut yeah oh okay yeah so I don't
directly into the computer with it yeah
yeah yeah I don't know much about it we
we actually are lat me and Hannah's last
podcast we recorded three times the
first time we got into an argument then
the second cuz we were yeah we got off
on some tangents and I was like and then
I was like a great weight got into
politics and then I was agreeing with
this one thing she was saying and then
she went back and corrected herself on
something she said then I was like oh no
now you've made me look terrible and
then she got mad at me I was like all
right and then we recorded the second
time in our microphone was not working
so part sounds like a great marriage
podcast yeah so by the third one she we
were like let's just do it yeah she was
not very happy but it was a good time I
could even tell him listening to the
first one you made you made a joke about
which first thought the PUC has called
we're having a good time yeah so just
for people to go listen to that but you
made a joke about keeping your set tight
and she made a joke about her being
tight and you just completely like
not even address right yeah you like
start laughing at how that she likes
making you uncommon to take it to a
dirty place real fast
she's a comedian awesome yes yes so it's
kind of like you know and she knows that
that makes me uncomfortable so she loves
to do it is that why you get along I
guess just because you that thing yeah
to the bounce yeah yeah did you guys
meet at a festival how did that actually
we met at an open mic in New York City
whoa she was living in Canada I was
living in Charleston and yeah we met and
we didn't start dating there but we
stayed in touch well if you're both was
it like one of those mics you like or in
the basement and it's 20 comics and no
one else yeah yeah I don't drink I quit
drinking like 29 right yeah yes yeah
yeah and yeah six years and she had
stopped drinking she doesn't drink much
but she wasn't drinking at all then so
we just kind of found each other that
way um and I think she had said she was
mad that day and she was like you know
she was like in this mode where she was
just gonna be hard and then she found me
and asked me a question and I think my
southern accent really threw her off and
she didn't know what to do because I was
just so nice I was like hey how you
doing yeah guys you do doesn't be slave
way exactly she's from Canada hearing a
southern accent that could be like oh
yeah you know like an alien almost yeah
totally yeah because I'm I like to I
like to really play the southerner role
in New York I
oh I bet you can really lean in unless I
get lost and then I like to pretend like
I'm a New Yorker you have like a white
voice you can go in right yeah I do that
I'll call it my honk Ebonics yeah if I
get down in there I can go there yeah
but I I'm um you know I've gotten braces
I'm you know a private school I'm very
affluent now yeah we can go there yeah
yeah totally
yeah like when you talk over this laughs
you got to clean it up right exactly
like yes sir I know I was speeding and
I'm sorry that's what I love about your
comedy is because like it's so authentic
and I remember the first time I saw you
was at punchline here in Atlanta oh you
were featuring I don't remember who the
headliner was I just remember you
featuring and it was I
who is this incredibly funny comedian at
moving at his own pace in his own
authentic way yeah my press yeah well
that's you know actually that's what
I've decided to do at this festival and
it's been the most successful for me
because if the laughing school won't now
well we get ya when we get you know yeah
I do 30-minute sets all the time
45-minute sets and then I get a 5-minute
set and I'm like oh I'm gonna cram eight
minutes right and then I'm like and then
I lose that slow style so I'm like you
know what I'm gonna do three minutes in
five minutes you know I'm just gonna
slow it down I'm gonna wave a lot having
a good time yeah you said that on your
Kimmel said you got like an applause
break over having a good time
what's that built into the set or did
you just react that way well I have this
joke where and I said it on there where
I'll say no trash in this ditch unless
it's white trash right and sometimes
that gets me a weird reaction I'm humble
so I like to remind them hey we're just
having a good time here don't freak out
it's fine yeah it works dude yeah and
that's how you got Kimmel was from being
at a festival right yeah I did
Bridgetown in Portland which I think
they're not doing anymore so I got in on
the last one yeah and yeah the the
Booker's from there sent my video to jfl
so I did a jfl audition just for laughs
yes yeah I didn't get that but the
Booker for Kimmel was at the jfl
audition so and how does that how does
that interaction even go down like what
it was very casual actually she was very
nice and she said what's her name yeah
what Hannah Crichton is her name and
she's great
and she she's like you ever done late
night I was like no she's like you want
to do Kimmel and I was like yeah she's
like all right email me and it was very
casual but then you know there was a
process where you have to send in a
video and then you have to send in like
an eight-minute video and then they go
okay we like that now narrow it down to
four minutes mm-hmm so and me I'm I
don't know I'm always recording and and
you never can understand what I'm saying
on my videotapes you know so I'm like it
took me forever it should have took me
two months I think it took
me six months how many submissions did
you I only did two okay and they liked
them both but I was like I would always
go no I don't want to send this video
either you couldn't it wasn't clear or
the audience didn't sound good I didn't
want to send them some video of me
getting a mediocre response and then
them go you know what we're okay
so you took you took is in six months it
took you to record two sets to submit to
them yeah and that's performing probably
five shows every weekend Wow yeah I was
just like I don't know I kept looking at
them each weekend just being like now I
don't want to send this yeah you better
perfectionist that way or is it I think
yeah I mean when I'm when I'm sending
something that I expect people to like
and booked me for me I want it to be
just right mm-hmm
I don't want to give them any reason to
go we don't like this guy even if it's
like the jokes may be good but even if
the video quality is bad that could be
yeah the deterrent even from right I
feel like if I'm booking a thing and I'm
asking someone to send me a video and
they send in some blurry video from a
cell phone I'm going you don't care
about this right you know yeah that does
make a difference so I want it to be
good mm-hmm but I feel like every time I
get a good camera angle and I crush it I
go back and watch and it's like it's
like you can't I don't know my voice is
off like you can't understand anything I
say
mm-hmm I've had I sent in videos to
America's Got Talent one time and the
all the producers I think are British
and they were like we can't understand
what you're saying
can you get a better rapport so I think
I don't know what to do is that the same
thing that happened with a Last Comic
Standing you had a little bit of a run
on there that didn't kind of blow up
yeah I don't know exactly what happened
either my theory is that Last Comic
Standing they're always looking for this
the story right so in my auditions I was
doing trailer park jokes because I could
use those jokes again throughout the
audition process but when I got to Last
Comic Standing I had three minutes and
they were like you can't use these again
once you use them he can't use them
again so I was like I only had a few
trailer park jokes I was like if I take
three minutes out of this it's gonna
kill my whole thing so I went with some
fish jokes and they got great laughs but
how
don't think that's what they were
looking for they're like we don't need
the fish joke comic like Oh we'll just
show pictures of him on the screen yeah
sure
yeah we'll show I'm looking real nervous
in the greenroom yeah it's your um your
story is very similar to a lot of
comedians I've heard where they're like
this is it oh yeah big break I'm gonna
post this and let the whole world know
my TV debut and then yeah you did that
right and it well they asked us to make
a post so I made one post and it got a
little bit of attention it was it was
good but I made it like a week early and
then the day that last time extending
was gonna air someone that I went to
high school with shared it they were
there was like a heartfelt post like it
was so nice but it was like my friend
that I grew up with is now gonna be on
national TV and so it got tons of likes
I mean it was it blew up man I watched
for two hours and never saw myself and
then I watched the whole season just
hoping at some point I would pop up yeah
maybe I'm in the finals really maybe I
won yeah maybe they'll go back and go
hey let's show some other comics yeah
but they never did then they just show
like a picture of you yeah I got two
pictures yeah green room just hanging
out just having a good time they were
like that's what this guy does just have
a good time
those are the stories that like I filmed
Comedy Central's roast battle okay and
they came to Atlanta and film that and I
was like okay I've interviewed enough
people to know this may not happen so I
didn't say anything like yeah post about
it they would who's gonna premiere in
Atlanta because they didn't tell me I
wasn't gonna air but when it aired I
wasn't even on it and I was like oh my
gosh
one thank goodness that wasn't my TV
debut like it went well I won the round
but it's like in hindsight that's not
really what I want to be the first right
and second is that it just didn't air so
if I was like hey I'm on Comedy Central
check me out and yeah and it airs and
they're like oh really Joel oh that's
what you're doing with your life so
interviewing people like you is really
providing me the wisdom that all right
just take it one one day at a time
yeah I think that you need those
disappointments I think yeah because
then when you
get like when I was I got Jimmy Kimmel
and I was like in my head I was like
until it actually showed up on TV I was
like it's not gonna show up yeah they're
gonna cut me last minute and then even I
was like the last five minutes of the
show so up and - I mean they kept saying
my name so I was like it's gonna happen
but I could just see them going you know
what we ran out of time
bump bump dusty yeah but so I think you
need that because you get to a point
where you you're not jaded but you're
almost like alright I you know you just
kind of have to feel like that you just
start making your own path mmm you know
you try to get your own following try to
do your own things and then anything
that you get like that is just a bonus
yeah that's a and that's another thing
that you've inspired me with is I'm
still based out of Atlanta yeah
because one I just love the scene here I
feel like the scene is race boiling
right now it is and there's a lot of
people even that you're seeing on TV
whether it be like performing a stand-up
set or acting or writing their that
started in Atlanta that have then moved
on or this oh yeah here yeah so I'm like
why move and start over when you just
you could get it done here like you're
based out of Nashville but you're still
having it on TV
yeah yeah I mean I think I don't know I
mean everybody always says that my next
step is to move to New York or LA yeah I
don't know I mean I like living in
Nashville I like my lifestyle and you
know I feel like that I'm getting better
at comedy all the time just as long as
you're writing and and performing all
the time mm-hmm just gonna get better I
mean I have no doubt that if I moved to
New York and was doing six sets a night
that I could really really work it you
know but I don't know right now I'm
pretty happy and I but you're right
though Atlanta's hot and that's what a
guy David Perdue was saying to me like
I've been on here yeah that he was like
I like limit he said the same thing he's
like I like that you made it on Kimmel
while still living in Nashville yes and
I like that too I mean I'm I'm I think
it's fun I like to go on stage and be
introduced as from Nashville if you if
I'm introduced as dusty slave from New
York City and I'm like I come out not
talk like this it's like that's not
gonna make
yeah you know he's an infiltrator yeah
how effective have you seen because you
did get Kimmel from going to bridge town
which is in Portland way far from
Nashville have you done a lot of
festival than have you seen them worth
it like the investment time travel ID
submission I don't do a lot I just think
it's important to do a good festival
okay but I think that it you know what I
mean I mean that's hard to figure out
but you just ask around you know be like
what's a good one but I think if you've
never done a festival these lower level
festivals are great because you like you
get into one and then when you apply for
the bigger one you can at least say I've
been to this festival this festival and
it at least you're doing something but
once you get into the bigger festivals I
don't see any reason to do the smaller
ones
mm-hm you know and I'm not trashing them
but I just sometimes you show up to a
festival and you know there's like no
one in the audience and you're like oh
this is like a showcase in my own
hometown you know I could do this
anywhere but it's like Atlanta this
festivals great Bridgetown was great I
mean you get a lot of audiences a lot of
people that don't normally see me and
I've found festivals the few I've done
the biggest piece may not be the shows
as much as just the people you meet yeah
that what you find similar yeah I mean
it's a little different for me
in Portland than Atlanta because Atlanta
you know I'm familiar with I get to come
here pretty good bit Portland I'd never
been to so it was fun to do these
Alabama trailer park jokes in Portland
you know and because it's fun for me
because I'm not going to Portland and
then trashing everyone that I grew up
with I'm just observing you know I mean
so I'm not like look at these
Hillbillies I'm like look at me I'm one
of those hillbillies you know and that's
what's fun to me yeah I like to you know
I think making fun of myself is fun
sometimes P I love to do that on social
media I love to bash my gigs and bash my
hotels not bash them but be like look at
this ridiculous thing I'm doing people
tell me that I shouldn't do that because
then it looks like I don't get good gigs
but I do get good gigs but I'm also
doing some bad gigs it's authentic yeah
I think that's what people gravitate
towards yeah
authentic see like I did this shinta see
I did a show in Tennessee recently
and on the marquee was just it said now
hiring servers and cooks comedy Saturday
night and I was there on Friday and
Saturday so they didn't even advertise a
Friday show and then they were like no
one's here you know we had a few people
but it was still fun but it's like it's
fun to make fun of that yeah you just
gotta roll with the punches really yeah
I mean one minute I was like at
hilarities in Cleveland a headline
tonight and then I featured for a great
comic and it was fun it was everything
was you know fancy the hotel was great
and then the next week you know they
don't even advertise my name I've been I
interviewed Sam Morrell on here and he
was talking about one night opening up
for Amy Schumer in front of like 10,000
people yeah very next night open my 10
people right right that juxtaposition
yeah yeah and that's what's so fun about
it like comedy really has a way to keep
you humble mm-hmm and Sam Morrell I
worked with him at The Laughing Skull
here I really liked him and I think he
has a he's a great joke writer yeah you
know and that's what's fun to me I like
people that write jokes yeah that's what
I really enjoyed about him and also just
people don't understand the specificity
of joke writing and when I asked Sam
about one of his Conan Conan sets and
just like the joke writing and I was
like you did this gesture here was that
all choreographed he's like I was just
reacting you like made no oh like it's
fun to see how fine-tuned some things
are so like even in your Kimmel set how
fine-tuned were mannerisms and pauses
like how dialed in was that set well
that sets pretty dialed in well Mike I
know what I want to do but yeah when I'm
when I'm just doing a longer set I mean
I'm waving just at everything like it's
a good way like if someone tells you I
can give them a little way like that
like you know okay or a peep people have
weird laughs sometimes so instead of
having to address it I just give them a
wave and the audience gets it they're
like we heard that too yeah I don't know
why it just I think that's something
that when the first time I saw you
perform like that subtlety mm-hmm it
just hits I don't know
why but sometimes it's like if they're
beat someone's hacked on you sometimes
it can be like a Jedi mind trick you
know you're like all right just quells
yeah a lot of times not always but a lot
of times you get people that are too
drunk to get anything you know they
don't they don't get if you and some
people just want to be made fun of
mm-hmm like after the show you didn't
make fun of them they're disappointed I
had a guy go I was like hey I like that
shirt and he's like yeah wore this so
you'd make fun of me I was like oh if
I'd have seen you I would have I would
have did it and I was just humoring him
and then he goes what would you have
said I was like all right well I'm not
just gonna roast you right here on
demand right yeah but not it yeah and
that's why you know like people one guy
was dressed like the day man or maybe
after the always sunny my Charley day
didn't done I don't know what day man or
night man he's like the bodysuit yeah we
had though like a full green suit or
something he was right up front and it's
like I feel like that guy he wore that
to be made fun of yeah everybody noticed
you dressed the obvious right how do you
normally deal with hecklers what have
you found to be the most efficient way
well I think for me just being nice is
the best way because if I don't if I if
I get like any kind of like aggressive
like I feel like the audience gets weird
because I've just been nice and fun the
whole time and of all of a sudden I'm
like shut up people are like Oh what
happened
mm-hmm but it's it's hecklers don't
really bother me so much it's just like
I had a guy in the front row at a show
and he was really drunk and he was just
he was just almost just making comments
to me that no one else could hear yo I'm
in there there's no I was like can you
guys kick this guy out of here and and
they didn't he was very muscular but I
tried to make fun of it a little bit and
then just be like and and and we worked
through it
we worked through it yeah but some of
those it's like there's nothing you can
do it's like I just like that guy to be
quiet and just leave but it's like is it
kind of guy that like even in a setup
he's commenting on your setups and it's
and he think I mean he he came up to me
after the show he was trying to hug me
he was like I was like dude like I don't
know just he was like but that helped
the hell
- I was like I just want you to know I
told him I said I just want you to know
you didn't help this show I don't want
you to leave here thinking that you
helped thinking that you were part of
the show you weren't I didn't enjoy it
and he didn't get it and as he was
leaving he was asking the feature he was
like I helped right yeah it's like did
that's the thing with a lot of hecklers
is they almost feel like they are
helping ya always most really aren't
even ill-intentioned they really just
think they're helping ya
so it is I guess being the nice that
nice piece is crucial to not lose the
audience yeah they all think he's well
not they'd all think he's helping but
yeah they're like what's wrong with this
guy up there why'd he get so mad yeah
but it's like you know when you're in a
zone and the audience is listening you
can really just tell your jokes and it's
a great time for everyone but one person
can ruin that whole mood yeah so that's
why being nice and just being like hey I
appreciate you being here well you will
you go back and forth with them or
you're like thanks for being here and
you kind of keep moving and that they
keep going then you come back - yeah I
try to just move on yeah move on but you
know sometimes like just repeating what
someone says can be funny like if they
say some weird thing you just repeat it
into the microphone then the audience
laughs and then and then it could be fun
but then you're it's almost like in
their minds they're like oh I gave him
that joke yeah I'm gonna give him
another way you know I'm gonna keep this
going
mm-hmm so yeah I mean I my goal is to
just be the kind of comic that no one
wants to heckle you're just too nice of
a guy they don't want to disturb you
yeah and I'm not I'm not touching on any
subject that could really be sensitive
to them but you know I did a show and
Sue st. Marie Michigan and I think they
have like a you know Native American
population so I have a joke about
baskets just a general basket joke and
then this lady goes baskets are sacred
to us oh I was like all right all right
if I can't make fun of baskets is this
too far it was a help for him oh yeah
yeah that's like religion joke
I'd move on from that yeah I was like
wow I had no idea make in front of a
sweet grass basket was was so intense
have you ever been booed on stage never
but-- never but not going would ya what
is like your most epic bomb failure
experience well I I open I've opened for
Aries Spears several times I have to
because he only books white opener right
that was a big controversy after our
interview yeah yeah yeah and and he the
first time we worked together there was
a regular show host feature Aries it's
great I loved it
second time I get there it's two-man
show just me and Aries and I'm better at
that now but for a long time
me hitting the stage first is not the
way to go and we need somebody even
someone just to come up and give
announcements but that is alright yeah
Aries Spears will be here soon right but
the whole weekend was good but the late
show Friday I was on stage and the
audience was just quiet I was just I did
joke after joke and they were just not
into it and then like some some guy made
a weird noise in the audience and I was
like oh someone's dying out there and he
goes no you're dying like I just shrank
down cuz he was so right I was like I
don't I don't even know what to say to
that how far into the set was that I
think I had about 10 minutes to go so
wasn't too early but I think I left the
stage a bit early I never do that I
always do time but I was like you know
what Aries is gonna do 90 minutes anyway
I'm just gonna get out of here what was
the makeup of the audience uh well I you
know it's hard to say I mean but you
know Aries is not total like an urban
comic you know it but yeah I think he
had a lot of free tickets on that Late
Show and I think free ticket people just
tend to be not invested in the show yeah
they're like we don't care about this we
got free tickets we're paying $30 for
drinks we don't care yeah I've been
there man I've definitely been there
where you're just it's even like five
minutes in and it's not going well and
you're like I still have 20 more minutes
yeah to figure something out here
yeah that's why if that's happening to
me after a few jokes I like to say I'll
go that's a good joke
I'll go that's a good joke guys you can
laugh at these you know feel free to get
in here laugh at these jokes let's have
a good time yeah yeah that's where that
we're having a good time I mean me and
my wife actually started saying that to
each other you know we just be like
we're having a good time but I started
saying that onstage for the shows when
when it didn't seem like people were
having a good time I would just go hey
we're having a good time I don't like to
ask I like to tell we're having a good
time
do you find that almost coerces them
into oh I guess we are having a good
time yeah I mean my thought is that a
lot of times if you're not doing well
the audience either feels bad for you or
they feel like this is what you do all
the time they're like oh this guy must
bomb all the time so I like to let them
know this is not how my shows normally
go mm-hmm you can laugh at these jokes
get in here and then I feel like that
they see a real side to you they're like
all right this is a real person up here
yeah he's self-aware he notices that
we're not into it
and Annie seems to be okay with it I can
imagine especially you transitioning
from feature to headliner
like feature set you're in the honey
spot it's oh yeah you're couched in the
ready to rock you only have to do 20 to
30 minutes you can just rock it out but
yeah that next level dude yeah it's
definitely a change yeah especially if
the feature I mean I'm pretty low energy
I'm fairly clean so it's like if the
feature is real high energy and real
dirty and they do well it can be a bit
hard to follow it can be you know just a
real moment of transition but but I
don't know yeah I mean I guess you just
work through it you know but I mean I've
had some none of my headlining sets have
been bad but I've had some that are you
know pretty mediocre where I like I go
out one night I was doing my CD pitch at
the end and I was like hey you know if
you want to hear what it's like when
people laugh at these jokes couple CDs
for you as I you guys don't think I
travel the country doing mediocre sets
like this yeah three bye bye Annie I
don't think I sold anything that night
but I
got a great laugh off that joke yeah but
that's why I think it's important just
to find your audience because there are
people that love my jokes so I just
wherever I go I just try to you know try
to make an effort to get people's emails
to try to get them to say hey you know
come back to the show next time I'm here
if you like what I'm doing I'll be doing
this kind of thing next time what are
some other tactics you use to generate a
dusty slave following well I use and and
and I don't know the total effectiveness
of any of these things but I use the
Facebook fan page because you can you
can sponsor an ad you can put some money
behind it and target it to a town and
specific demographics and you can see
like I can tell that the people that
watch my videos are from twenty-five to
forty five and mostly men apparently
women aren't that into my stuff and okay
yeah it's always weird to see that
though when I pull up and it's like 80%
of the lessons are for men and you know
so I'm like okay so but it's accepting
knowing your audience and just totaling
down on totally and then it's like so
you can target two people when you go
into those towns and then it shows up on
their Facebook feed and then I like to
collect emails and just even I don't I
don't send out a monthly newsletter
maybe I should but I just like to say
hey I'm coming back in a week get some
tickets come see me mm-hm and when I'm
headlining it really works it's
different when I'm featuring because I
feel like they act also have to really
like the headliner you know to translate
to you right if I'm like hey I'll be you
know I'll be in Tampa and I'll be with
this guy if they don't like that guy
they're like I don't know it's not worth
it and to gather emails do you have like
a clipboard that you have emails me I
type in your phone I just do a notepad I
do a notepad and then I go home and
struggle to figure out people's drunk
handwriting oh yeah yeah okay they you
make them write it down and yeah yeah
yeah and they yeah and it's like I'm
always amazed at people's handwriting
I'm like wow this makes no sense
oh I host a weekly show here in a
Decatur Georgia on Wednesdays and I'll
just collect emails through people
writing and half of them I can't even
input oh yes like people don't know how
to write anymore right yeah
but I thought about you know getting
like the keyboard thing on an iPad but
then I thought well you know they're
drunk and they're typing that is that
gonna it's gonna be clearer to read that
they type their email wrong right yeah
they just steal it right cuz I want to
just pass around an iPad and my wife is
like what's gonna prevent people from
just stealing that yeah well I have a
wife to talk me off the ledge of being
too philanthropic yeah yeah then they
got all your emails too
yeah yeah yeah I mean I used to head out
the square where I would use for merch
and I have a outer box OtterBox whatever
it's got on the on the phone and the
thing wouldn't fit so I would have to
take the case off and then I was always
so afraid I was like I'll hold it you
just sign it and then I felt like that I
had to explain to everyone that I that
this phone cost a lot of money and they
don't give these away anymore they don't
let us sign a contract and get a free
phone so I'm like I can't break this
yeah you have to let me hold it selling
merch is something I've just started to
tip my toe in the water on and it can be
it can be difficult I may do a show in
front of 300 people and maybe not sell
anything I'm gonna do it was show in
front of 30 people and sell 10 things
have you found to be the best way of
selling merch well I I just I feel like
it's you gotta have I feel you gotta
have a good sales pitch it's like I try
to keep my merch pitch funny sometimes
sometimes I'll get applause breaks on my
merch pitch because you know I don't
know I just work on making it funny I
don't want that to be a dip in the show
I don't want to be like we're not doing
comedy anymore
now I'm selling you things it's like I'm
selling you things and we're still doing
jokes but sometimes it can just be you
know really humbling to stand at your
merch table while people pass by and
make no eye contact with you I want to
be like hey I'm not I'm not a homeless
man I'm not broke I'm just if you want
it buy it if not you don't have to look
at me you don't have to go like this but
they I think that sometimes when I do
the worst I sell the most stuff I had a
show not too long ago where I was
tempted I didn't feel that great about
it I was tempted to not even go set up
and then I sold a ton of stuff mm-hmm it
was very strange yeah
but it's like sometimes I think that we
think as comedians that we're not doing
well
but the audience has a great time I know
I watch comedy shows all the time and
sometimes I never laugh and I enjoy the
whole thing you know what I mean mmm
yeah it's like think we we think that
you know on stage were like gotta have
laughs every 30 seconds I need a laugh a
laugh and it's like sometimes people are
just enjoying listening to you yeah you
know I have found some of the people I
see in the audience not laughing those
are the ones that come to you after and
we're like you just made my yeah week or
month yeah yeah yeah I've had guys so
they sit there with their arms crossed
and look mad the whole time and after
the show they're like hey great set man
mm-hmm I'm like oh well you could have
got a cracked a smile I focused on you
the whole job you ruin my CV yeah for me
yeah but are you had fun what are some
what if some of your merged pitches can
you give us an example of how you make
it funny well I like to say I'll say I
got I'll pitch my CD and then I'll say
I'll be out there after the show I'll be
out there selling these or at the very
least I'll be out there holding them and
that actually got me an applause break
and doesn't seem funny at all right here
but I got me an applause break in in a
club in Lexington I said well be at
least I'll be out there holding them and
I was like I don't know how to react to
this applause break I feel like you guys
are like this guy is very self-aware and
yeah and then I you know I used to say
you know yeah you know I would I would
pitch the CD and I would say you know
let's say you'd like to buy this but
you're not interested in listening to it
that's okay
in fact you can buy this for me and then
just go out in the parking lot and just
throw it down on the ground I'll just
pick it up try to sell it in the next
year and it's just like I'm just trying
to let them know without saying it that
I'm like I don't care if you buy it I
only want you to buy it if you really
want to like I've had people just come
up and give me money before they're like
I don't want to buy anything but here's
some money hmm
and I'll take that too but I would
rather people buy things because they
really like the show it seems you've
touched on self-awareness a couple times
in this have you found that too more
self-aware you become almost the more
are successful or I don't the better
your comedy gets I mean who knows but I
yeah I think that it's important to to
know when you're not doing well and to
also know when you are doing well like I
know comics that every time they have a
said it'll be a good set and they come
off and they're like oh I hated that I
hated this audience my jokes are no good
then it's like you gotta take it easy on
yourself but I also know comics that
will bomb the entire time and then come
off like yes you know and I'm like you
gotta you got to know when you're you
got to know when you're doing well and
knowing you're not mm-hmm and you get I
don't know it's like maybe there's no
way to ever fully know but yeah it's
important to be like alright
this jokes cuz I'll write a new joke and
I'll try it out for a week if it's not
getting anything I'm like either I got
to rewrite this or I got stop telling it
you know even if you really like the
joke if it's bombing every time it's no
need to tell that joke but I think
self-awareness can play into your comedy
writing as well and what material you
being aware of how you look on stage how
being perceived can drive your writing
yeah yeah I mean yeah I mean I always
just try to keep it like even like I'm
just like I'm just up here telling jokes
I'm not trying to to change anyone's
mind on anything you know but I also am
NOT trying to say that that's what I'm
doing
you know I'm not up there on stage being
like I'm not gonna talk about anything
because there are comics that talk about
things and they do that well and I want
them to keep doing that but that's not
what I do
I'm gonna do trailer-park jokes and talk
about a TV that I dropped off in
goodwill I mean that's my job
cuz that's what I'm doing I mean at the
Cracker Barrel a lot you know I mean but
that fits yeah the self-awareness that
fits like if you were to say the brand I
mean that all fits into that filter yeah
yeah and I think it's important too to
do that without like as a southern comic
I feel like you can fall into the trap
of I don't want to say hacky because but
but you can get cheesy with it maybe as
though and it's like that's trying to
try to do funny trailer-park jokes
without being too cheesy and even if you
have a cheesy joke I think it's fun to
throw it a nice twist at the end like I
this joke where I would say I say when
you hang out with a lot of broke people
all the time like I do
everything's always fancy to them like
the other day I was hanging out with my
mom which i think is funny nobody ever
gets that part and we were out to dinner
and she was like this is so fancy and
I'm like mom it's Olive Garden of course
it's fancy because when I say that
mom it's Olive Garden I can feel the
audience be like Oh cheesy joke and then
when you go of course it's fancy it
brings them all around but that's also a
joke depending on the town people in the
audience are like I don't get that joke
the odd garden is fancy you know I mean
that's our restaurant that's where I
went for my anniversary right buddy you
take it easy on the Olive Garden
it's the only white tablecloths we have
in town people of your own ilk yeah feel
that way oh yeah yeah I mean my dad is
not the guy for me to test out material
on yeah I mean like preaching to the
choir yeah he's like I don't I don't get
that you know you know I mean my I would
if I think my my parents maybe even
judge my comedy by the level of success
that I have if it were just based on my
jokes I would I think they would think
that I was not successful are they proud
of you like they are they are but I just
mean my jokes are not written for my
parents yeah I mean not that anyone's
probably writing jokes with their
parents I don't know any comedy that
comics that are like I'm writing this
for my dad yeah that's like make sure my
dad's cool with it right right right are
they cool like on Kimmel you're making
you know trailer park jokes are they
like hey why would you joke about that
or is it oh no my parents are divorced
my dad never lived in a trailer park so
he doesn't care at all and my mom thinks
it's hilarious good yeah okay yeah yeah
it's long that's why I try to like my
whole goal was to make fun of things
about my life growing up without
trashing the way I grew up you know
because for whatever reason however I
was raised the way I was raised it is
what it is I think everybody did a great
job but there is still funny stuff that
surrounds it you know if my parents
could have been millionaires I'm sure
they would have loved that
did his start I was embarrassing like
did you almost have to warm up to the
even talk about those personal things I
think no I mean not at doing comedy
really helped me like you know growing
up I always had friends that weren't in
trailer parks I had a few friends that
were but I mean most of my friends in
high school and stuff they didn't live
in trailers you know so it's like it was
always a little I was a little
self-conscious about it all the time
so being able to talk about it on stage
just wipe that all the way it became now
like a source of pride huh and it and it
works like that for people after shows
people come up to me and they're like
hey I grew up in a trailer park too
which I feel like is the only time they
were ever able to be proud of it so
that's what you know I'm just trying to
say that that world exists mmm and
there's stuff in it that's funny
but we don't have to trash those people
what has been the the feedback after
Kimmel and putting that on the the
national stage what kind of people been
reaching out to you that way well you
know I don't know that late-night is
exactly what it used to be and the
soldiers knew yeah because you know I
mean there's there's a lot of late night
shows there's Netflix a lot of people
aren't even watching TV now mm-hmm but
it definitely helps me get respect
amongst comics respect amongst my family
and also you know it helps with bookings
I mean if a ton of people have a late
night but but that many more Plus don't
have late night so it helps you put you
at a next level to where people take you
more seriously
but it doesn't it wasn't like oh this
guy did Kimmel he's headlining this club
this club this club now you know it's
not like that but it definitely helps
what did it what did something couldn't
really change anything
well it's like close a lot of places
that I feature too at I got bumped up to
headliner because of that because I have
a credit and then yet opened some doors
to some things and even being at this
festival this year I mean I felt like
that I was at a different like because
most of the festivals I go to people are
from LA Chicago and New York I'm usually
the only Nashville comic at a festival
this year we had a couple of people here
which is great but so it puts me at a
different level now now people are like
oh
this guy lives in Nashville and he's
been on Kimmel I can it puts me almost
at a I don't know I feel like it puts me
in a different space it gives me more
confidence to you know it's it's done a
lot but not necessarily in the ways that
you can see if that makes sense and you
mentioned before we got on air here that
were tongue out being at the Laughing
Skull Fest this year and the networking
piece and have you been able to get a
lot of networking done but there's a
there's a balance between like you want
to meet people but you don't want to be
that guy right like where was the
industry like stand out how do you walk
that line well that's tough for me but I
had my industry showcase that I had at
where you know and that is you know the
showcase where all the industry people
are at mm-hmm it went great
I had a great set and it was the right
environment for me I mean it was the
kind it was the City Winery which is
almost like some of the big comedy clubs
that I do I was like this is my audience
so I felt like it was gonna go well so I
had this comfort level and I didn't do
any jokes from my Kimmel set my that was
my goal like if the people saw me and
then they were like who's this guy
and then when watched my Kimmel said
they would go oh he didn't do any of
those jokes that was my goal I didn't
want them to go see me do well and then
go watch Kimmel and go oh that's all the
jokes he has so it went well and then I
just kind of I just try to put myself in
the position to be available for people
to talk to me
you know like at the after-party I'm not
always surrounded by a crowd of people
you know so I kind of hang I'll talk to
one or two people are here and there and
it it makes me available and I'll you
know I'll be sneaky about it and
position myself next to someone and go
you know so they can hopefully go hey we
really enjoyed your set and then I can
talk to them you know shake their hand
or if I see them alone I can go over and
just just say hey I just try to talk to
people like regular people even though
they are these people of importance that
I need things from I also I'm like you
know what I'm booked up for for several
months if they don't talk to me it's not
the end of the world I want them to but
I'm still gonna do my gig in Arkansas
next weekend you know what I mean
so but yeah I think it's you know I've
worked in the corporate world like I was
a sales rep I sold pesticides for a long
time that's so perfect yeah I see a TV
show of you doing yeah yeah that's so
perfect so you know I had to get used to
talking to Lowe's managers and Home
Depot managers and and even though it
doesn't seem the same when you're in
that world yeah I need things from those
managers just like I need things from
industry people now I can still do my
job without them but they can make my
job a lot easier how do you how do the
conversations go well again I just try
to talk I like a bellhops for a little
while at this place and they always they
always have the earpiece and they would
tell you the person's name and you had
to go out there and you go oh mr.
Jenkins welcome back to the and I'm not
good at that I'm not good at being a
phony person right so I just I feel like
it's important for me to do well and
then to see me do well and then our
conversation is different I'm not trying
to prove myself to them in conversation
which is important because I always do
this even at an open mic if I go to a
new town and I don't know anyone there I
don't really talk to people at the open
mic until after the show's over because
then they've seen me be funny and now we
can talk on that level yeah there was
this movie that I saw a long time ago it
was a movie called the tayo of Steve and
I don't know if I'm pronouncing that
right but it's ta o the Tao of Steve and
it was just this kind of overweight guy
and he was talking about how he picked
up women Randy and one of his rules was
to let them see you be great at whatever
you're great at you know so it's like if
you're great at horseshoes you go to a
party where there's horseshoes that and
you make sure that girl sees you be good
at that you know and then that just
gives you an end so I think that is how
I approach comedy it's like comedies
what I'm good at
there's not ton of things that I am good
at but comedy is and so I let them see
me be good at comedy and then I talk to
them that's mistake I think a lot of
younger comics make like how long you
been doing comedy about 10 years about
10 years yeah I mean you know five years
really working it five years figuring it
out well you started in like 2004
and overalls and no shoes right and you
quit yeah yeah that's not my mode yeah I
did it and I had I had a great I was
doing improv and I had a buddy that I
was doing improv with he's like you
should do comedy and do that country
character I'm like oh you mean be me and
but we'd really Larry the Cable Guy was
popular really popular at the time so we
did the overalls I was doing no shoes oh
my god no I was just I had no idea what
I was doing and in the first couple of
times I did it it went great so I was
like all right I like this and that
started bombing and there's nothing like
bombing and then still sitting there
with your overalls on yeah you're like
you got this whole getup on and now
you're bombing so I was like I don't
want to do this anymore so I just quit
and then actually that same guy in 2008
texted me and he's like hey I got this
show I need someone to do stand-up do
you want to do it and I was like gal do
it and then we wrote me and him wrote
that letters of the alphabet joke that I
have off my first CD which if you
haven't heard it's really fun and off
making that fudge and that's what the
album's called
it's a good time yes it is and we wrote
that and I did that on stage and it went
great and I was like man I love this and
so slowly from there I started getting
back into it and it was in 2012 when I
quit drinking so I did four years of
doing open mics half drunk and then
partying right after I yeah and then
once I quit drinking
it really just I don't know my brain
cleared up and I just went to writing
and it was much better did you have like
a problem drinking me like hit like a
rock bottom where you yeah I don't know
I mean I think beat up myself just you
know I just it was more I don't think it
was so much like the drinking they are
like an alcoholism thing it was more
like once I start drinking then I'm like
I just want to keep drinking and then I
wanna I want to smoke a pack of
cigarettes I want to eat a whole pizza
and just I was getting fat I couldn't
breathe and then I was just like I
looked bad I was like this is not
working right so I yeah so once I quit
drinking I mean my health improve
moved I started eating better because I
wasn't you know I wasn't I didn't need
to you know you don't want to wake up
hungover and eat a salad you know what I
mean no one's thinking of healthy
choices on a hungover day so I would go
to bed eating a pizza and wake up eating
the Hardee's sausage biscuit yeah I used
to get the loaded omelet biscuit from
Hardee's home I actually sometimes would
get the loaded omelet biscuit and the
biscuits and gravy and after I ate the
biscuits and gravy I would put some
gravy on the loaded omelet biscuit the
double dip if you yeah yeah and then I'm
just eating that wondering why I'm
getting fat right and can't breathe I
might what's happened why my bad at
comedy yeah I can't breathe
I was yeah the last day the day I
decided to quit drinking I was trying to
smoke a cigarette with my roommate and I
didn't even have like the lung capacity
to pull the cigarette and I was like
what am i do oh so I just threw it out
and then I just quit mm-hmm I was like
that's it
and your comedy took off from there yeah
I mean it you know I had a I had about a
month where I was even deciding whether
I wanted to keep doing calm Wow because
quitting drinking I was like well I'm
gonna be in the bars all the time and
I'm like I was hosting a weekly open mic
so I was still doing that and then I was
like I don't know and then I was
thinking about quitting but I had
already entered a contest in Charleston
so then I went and then I won that and I
was like all right I'm gonna keep doing
and then I won another contest shortly
after that in Charleston and I was like
all right let's keep this going yeah I
just got I you know I was still doing
well even when I was drinking but I
really tightened up and I could just
being at the party I haven't seen
anybody really make a fool of themselves
right but I could see how I would make a
fool of myself in these parties mmm-hmm
get carried away yeah I mean like there
was a guy he was he was carrying around
a bottle of fireball and he offered it
to me and I I was I Oh No but you know
six years ago I would have been like
let's do this second hand fireball yeah
me and you we're drinking this oh that's
and that's saying when you get that
early success like a contest is a
comedian you you almost feel entitled to
like where's my TV special why am I not
oh yeah I mean the disappointment racks
up in comedy I mean you got a deal with
disappointment or it's never gonna work
very few people get noticed right away
and even getting noticed only means you
know some next level of success I mean
no you know people will be like oh that
guy just where'd that guy come from
you know like somebody like like Bert
Kreischer for instance I feel like I
just work with him I feel like he's 45
and I think he's been doing comedy for
20 years yes most people just found out
about him in the last few years mhm and
it's like they're like feel like it's an
overnight success and it's like no this
guy's been working it for years and now
he's got his deserved break and he's
great his shows crush he was he was not
feeling well but we can we work together
and he was still crushing it every show
like he would be like Oh like we went to
lunch and he almost couldn't talk he had
lost his voice but by the time he got to
show Tom he's he's ready to go and it's
like because that's he's a professional
he's done it for 20 years somatically
some of these youtube stars and I'm not
trashing them good for them but they
barely done comedy and they got this
huge amount of success and then their
shows aren't good because they haven't
put in the work got to put in the work
yeah and and I don't I don't know oh
yeah the first contest I won in
Charleston I mean this is sarcasm but I
thought there was gonna be a parade you
know I thought I've won the competition
Super Bowl it was immediate letdown I
had this girl that was I was gonna go on
a date with she stood me up the next day
so it's like immediate letdown yeah
and so you learned to deal with that in
comedy if you don't my improv teacher
told me a long time ago he said if you
can't handle a bad set that you might as
well quit now because you're gonna have
a lot more of them you know yeah and
it's true I mean the moment that I think
that I can never have a bad set again I
have three of them you know oh and it's
always that's what I get worried when
things are going well I'm like oh
something bad is brewing oh yeah yeah
and a comic another natural comic at the
festival Aaron Webber he
said to me which is the exact thought
I've had a lot of times he said my set
he had a set the other night that went
great he was like this set went so well
I thought they were laughing at me he's
like I thought my fly was down or
something and I've had those moments
where you're like that this shouldn't be
this funny I don't understand what's
happening mm-hmm this joke is on me
there's a picture of me as a baby behind
me it's gotta be totally you know yeah
but how do you like you said with Bert
Kreischer he was sick but he was able to
overcome that adversity and perform do
you have any specific habits or anything
that helped you to even when you're not
feeling it to still take it to the
performance level even though you don't
want to I think there's something that
just happens when you get on stage
you're just like even if you don't feel
well you get up there and it just it
just kind of all goes away now I I
haven't had any challenge of like trying
to do it with the flu but I did I wasn't
doing a bar show and in DC and it was
raining it was cold I had lost my voice
and my shoes got soaked so I was asked
and I was sick I was cold and so I took
my shoes off because they were soaked
and I did the whole show with barely a
voice in my socks Wow and it went great
I mean it didn't go as well as it would
have gone had I not had those things but
the fact that I was still able to do
like 40 minutes with no shoes and no
voice I was pretty proud of that but
it's just like yeah you get the energy
you get the rush you're like this is
great doing comedy I'm not selling
pesticides anymore yeah no well all
these bookings you're getting is this
through a manager are you doing this
through word-of-mouth yeah I got him I
have a manager and I also have someone
that's that's kind of an agent for me
she really she's really helped me a ton
she's I say she's kind of an agent for
me because she's not an agent she works
at a comedy club but she's really helped
me a ton just her being able to reach
out but yeah a lot of it's my own stuff
too it's just I email I'll send a short
video what I always like to do is I like
to send one like two-minute video and
then one like video length of whatever
I'm trying to do with the club
like if I'm trying to feature I'll send
them a 30-minute video but I'm like I
just figured the chances are they're not
gonna want to watch a 30-minute video
but they will watch a two-minute video
so I give them the two minute if they
like it then I'm saying here's proof
that I can do the time that I'm saying I
can do how do you word those emails I
just I'm just always nice I feel like
that I always have my own little three
P's of email I say it's patience
persistence and being polite because
it's so easy to feel rejected
like if a Booker doesn't email you back
or emails you back without a gig it's so
easy to be like oh this guy hates me
this doll is his personal I even had a
Booker at this festival this weekend she
they had given me a ton of bookings one
year and then the bookings have fallen
off a bit and she said to me she was I
don't think that this is a personal
thing she's like this is it's just you
know there's a million comics and a lot
of people are bringing their own
features so it's gigs or you know
there's less and less of them but yeah I
mean I think that it's important to be
persistent like I'm at least a monthly
email to these bluntly email with a boom
with the Vails
just saying hey these are the dates I'm
open not begging for spots because I
don't want to be the guy begging for it
I don't want to be the guy that the club
is finally like all right this guy's
hassled us let's just get him a spot
right I don't because even if I get in
it goes well I'm still in their mind I'm
like the hasslein guy and I don't want
to be that some people call it hustling
some people call it hassling I think it
can be a little bit of both you know
yeah but it's also like important to be
patient because it's like you I've
emailed Booker's for a year and not
gotten any response and then suddenly
they're like hey are you available this
weekend and I'm like yeah and and then
sometimes you are sometimes you aren't
but if you are it's like boom now you're
in and you've waited it out it's such a
comedy such a long game that it's like
the moment you think that you're above
an old Booker and you want to be like I
don't need their gigs anymore suddenly
you're like I wish I had those gigs you
know I mean yeah
it's like you know you get a grit you
one week you'll get great gigs hype a
ton of show sell a bunch of merch the
next week you're at a you're at a gig
that doesn't pay as well you don't sell
a ton of merch but it's like even doing
that gig it still filled out your
calendar so you're making a little money
and you're getting better at comedy are
you organized and tracking shows and how
they went now like how organized are you
on the backend cuz you're a business
organization could be a big part of
running that business efficiently yeah I
mean I'm pretty organized but I also
have a pretty good memory of what that
show was like I mean I I can you know
you always remember the bad ones more
than the good ones I think but I I think
that that helps to know this this is how
I did there like I'd normally if I go to
a club and do a guest spot because I'll
do that sometimes I'll say hey you know
I'd like you to see me can I just come
to a guest spot and I'll do it for free
you know no hotel it'll cost me money
but almost every time I would say 95% of
the time I've done that I've gotten a
booking out of it but I did I went to
Milwaukee one time to this place and it
was a Thursday night and they had four
people in the club and I did five
minutes and never made them laugh and I
still talk to the owner after I was like
as I I don't know why you would book me
based off that set but I would like to
come back and I didn't but it's like I
get it like if I'm booking I mean I
booked a show with Jamie's and it's like
if I'm booking a show and the guy asking
for the spot just bombed I'm like I
don't know what my incentive is to book
you you know I mean it is a business
like and I get that comedy clubs want to
make money and and they me I mean you
know it's like a restaurant if you go to
a restaurant and you eat this meal and
the meals terrible you're like I'm
probably not coming back to this place I
feel like it's the same for a comedy
club if you come in you see a show and
it's terrible you're like I may not go
back to that mm-hmm
you might give it another shot but but
maybe not you know what I mean and so
I'm like I try to look at it from that
standpoint it's like let's give them
something good all the time like I know
a club and from what I understand they
won't do and
open mic because they don't want people
to see bad comedy at the club and an
open mic you know is they can be great
but they can be terrible I can leave a
bad taste in your mouth yeah
yes and ruin comedy for you right right
yes right and especially if you're in a
city not known for comedy like if you go
to New York City and you see an open mic
and it's terrible
you're gonna you're probably just gonna
say that's a terrible open mic but if
you go to Nashville and see a bad open
mic you're gonna go comedies bad in
Nashville because it's not known for
that you can see bad music in Nashville
and go that was just a bad show because
it's known for music you know what I
mean I know exactly what you yeah so
it's like I don't know I just think that
it's you want to I think in that Steve
Martin book I read part of it I usually
read about half of a book and then I
feel like I got it yeah yeah he says
something like you want to be good all
the time so you can be great sometimes
mm-hmm and I think that's important and
that's sometimes the challenge for
trying out new jokes like if I'm in a
I'm in a club sometimes I'm in a club
and I feel like I'm barely surviving
like they're laughing but one bad joke
could send them to their phones yeah
familiar feeling but then then sometimes
the shows going so well and I'm like I
don't want to tank this with a new joke
make out but so it's like that challenge
of balancing and then open mics to it's
like I can go do a joke at an open mic
and it could crush I know my good new
joke and then I take it to a regular
Club in front of regular people and
there they're not having it because it
could be some weird reference I could
make a he-man reference at an open mic
and everyone's gonna laugh but in the
general world there they might not even
remember that guy yeah because I don't
know if you've seen what he man actually
looks like on the cartoon recently but
it's pretty funny I'm not yeah yeah you
should check that he's like a little
bottle blonde bob haircut with some
bangs and it's like this is he-man this
was the strong guy that we liked only
using like tights
I'm guessing oh yeah but a brief yeah
okay yeah and he-man was great I love
that show as a kid but watching the
intro you can
just type in he-man intro on YouTube
it's pretty funny all right you all have
homework out there yeah
go watch the he-man it's ro and if you
just want a funny video you should watch
this video called it's about Karate Kid
how Daniel was the real bully huh it's
so fun and interesting it's nothing to
do with me now watch it the other day
and I yeah my buddy has a cool YouTube
channel yeah it's funny though it's
worth a watch you've been getting on
YouTube or you've you've been trying to
build the channel and yes I mean I'm
just trying to do something that I like
doing that I also think it's fun I mean
I like country music so I have this
thing where I do top 5 country songs and
I just try to do different topics but
mainly it's just me like I love to
recommend songs to people because I
think that country music is great but I
think that if you you go into the wrong
country you could be like oh I hate this
so I'm trying to show great country and
I like 70's 80's 90's country so I'm
trying to show that off and it does fine
I think the videos are great if you like
country music you'll love them do little
Conway Twitty in there yeah I got a
little Conway Twitty I love him but I
just got to find some more categories to
fit him in you know what I mean I think
I want to put him in in in kind of a he
has a song called lay you down I'd love
to lay you down and I think that first
verse is is really pretty it's pretty
sexual Conway Twitty is pretty sexual
hello darlin yeah yeah and and I don't
think that people see him that way but
he's pretty sexual and that I'd love to
lay you down once he gets into the
second third verse you realize that he's
talking about his wife and it's a sweet
song but the first one doesn't feel
sweet at all it's like an art Kelly yeah
out there he's basically saying in this
song he's like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna mess around with you right here
I'm just letting you know I'd like to
have sex with you
that's basically what that first verse
says I could tell you a lot of things
but what I'm saying is I'd like to have
sex with you not a good icebreaker for
bookers you don't want to open up with
that yeah exactly
well thanks for doing this man yeah
seriously I've been a fan of you for a
while now to see you on Kimmel was
awesome and now to get us out yeah sit
down with you and even just
see how that all happened is great yeah
and with this video people can see how
awkward that I am in when I'm sitting
down I think up this is I don't sit on
stairs a lot and I'll move my hands and
I'm always like this that's why the wave
helps me with comedy because I get to do
something with my hand because I'm
always like this I'm doing and then I'm
I touched my glasses and I touched my
hat and then I touched my fans I don't
know what it is I'm like a third-base
coach you know this is my first
interview sitting crisscross applesauce
yeah so it's like a first for both of us
in stairs yeah that's my air B&B here
out here in ATL College Park we out
cheer yeah I feel like Ludacris had some
college Park references total that's why
I was worried about coming down here
with all this equipment I was like am I
going to be house is clearly
gentrification at its finest very nice
people here so in closing is there
anything else you want the world to know
well I have a podcast that I've started
called we're having a good time podcast
with my wife Hannah Hogan and she's also
comic and it's a fun time and then you
know all my social media is at dusty
slay that's dus dy SLA why and yeah I
mean it's fun I try to use all my social
medias Facebook Instagram Twitter for
different things like if I share a
picture on Instagram I try not to share
it on Facebook and Twitter I try to have
them be separate entertainment things so
if you follow all them you'll get
different stuff interesting what's the
strategy behind that well I just don't
want like I feel like sometimes if an
Instagram post gets a ton of likes I'll
share it on Facebook but I I'm just
trying to make those be different things
you know like so you get a little
something different like if I have
something that I that's a little edgier
or I don't think is this funny I'll put
it on Twitter because you know my aunt
doesn't follow me on Twitter you know I
mean but a Facebook I got a lot of
relatives so if it's edgy I don't want
to put it on Facebook you know cuz I got
and then and then Instagram I feel like
is just a fun picture thing yeah you
know so is is Facebook more you use that
more for the promo side of things yeah
that's definitely where I'm like I'm
doing a show but I do promo on all of
them for sure and I try not to be
annoying about it I try to keep my promo
funny too but I gotta let people know
when shows are at
because I always I always post a picture
and I feel like oh I'm being really
annoying about my promotion and then and
then when the weekends over someone will
go oh I didn't know you were in st.
Louis and it's like well I posted it
five times right I don't know how he had
missed it it's like they wait it's their
way of saying sorry we missed you yeah
we couldn't make it we were doing stuff
even though they saw all five yeah
people will email me people will message
me and they'll be like oh when you come
into town when you come into town I'm
like next week I'll be there and and
they're like oh we're busy Thursday I'm
like I'm there Friday - they're like
busy then well three show Saturday ah
can't do it can't find a babysitter yeah
just can't do it saving up money to go
see Carlos Mencia right right we don't
have time yeah I had this guy they used
to work in the bank that I used to go to
all the time and he I would always tell
him about comedy I was I mean I was
always inviting him to my shows $10 my
shells were and he never would come and
then one day I went in there and he goes
I finally saw a comedy show and I was
like oh great
who'd you see it he's like Aziz Ansari
cost him like 70 bucks I was like all
right well appreciate appreciate you
coming to my ten dollar show you know
you work in the bank get some money out
of here oh I have that perspective
inside the comedy world we're like oh
this is very important and everybody
knows everything about comedy
yes it was so cool and then the most
people are like who like no they had
their own TV show no I don't know yeah
oh yeah unless it's like the 1% of
comedy people have no idea most all
right yeah yeah my dad told me I should
be more like Jeff Dunham
and get some puppets you know I mean
Larry is good to get you some puppets my
dad came to a show that I bombed ad in
Columbus Georgia I mean I bombed in
Columbus oh yeah yeah front of my dad
yeah yeah cuz Columbus I'm from Alabama
so Columbus is pretty close to where I'm
from I was doing a show my dad came my
dad came with his wife his cousin and
his wife and and then my cousin's
friends from church and then his nephew
and his wife and I bombed so bad uh-huh
and then the next week my dad was in
Gatlinburg and he went to the comedy
barn and posted about how great the show
was you know
and I've wrote on there all finally
seeing some real comedy right and it got
no likes I got no love for that I don't
think they got my sarcasm well I get it
that's why I'm a fan of you man yes
first time I saw you I was like this guy
is a great comedian and he's also an
authentic comedian so yeah yeah thank
you
no problem thank you yeah I don't think
it's fun to be I don't know it's more
fun to be authentic you know that's why
I like to make fun of myself because I'm
not beating myself up but we all should
be of the laughing ourselves you know I
mean my life is fun but I don't but I
like to make fun of myself I find myself
at some interesting situations you know
I think it's crucial for longevity too
you can only fake it for so long yeah
totally totally and that's why it's hard
for me to want to leave the south
because I you know to live I love to go
to New York I love going to LA I love to
go to the Midwest it's so fun to visit
these places but I feel like if I move
out of my environment then I'm gonna
it's gonna change me because I will
adapt to wherever I'm living you know
but maybe it'd be alright maybe maybe a
maybe I'd look good with a New York
accent
you know are you thinking about moving
is that like I don't know it's it's
always something I'm thinking about
right but I don't know I go there I like
it and then I'm happy to leave right I
mean you just go there you can go there
do the work and then Yaak home I love it
I love strolling around New York I like
to put my headphones in listen to some
country music while I'm rolling around
in the subway it's great but yeah I
don't know I mean living there it's just
it's expensive too and it's like I'm do
comedy full-time right now I don't know
that I could do comedy full-time and pay
you know two grand a month in rent
that's I'm at the point now where I'm
like I'll move if it's for work I'm not
gonna move to just keep doing a shows
like I'll move if there's like a job
right on the other end of that move yeah
that's gonna move for the sake of saying
I did yeah and I just I you know I was
thinking about like today I was like I'm
not that crazy about getting back into
the struggle like I found a comfortable
life right I'm not but then I saw
weirdly this Frederick Douglass quote
that said where there is no struggle
there is no progress and
is he talking to me right now yeah but
you can create struggle within your own
like with where you are trying out new
things and new like that is hard cast in
itself people to understand how much
work a podcast is yeah out of time that
goes into a podcast like you said the
first one you guys recorded three times
yeah and you thought you're just gonna
sit down and just be s Pharrell yeah so
there's a lot of work and that's a
struggle so you can find struggles
without being dramatic about it and it's
yeah well that's true that is true I did
yeah I thought it's he I mean it was a
whole political post about Frederick
Douglass's life about being a slave to
where he got to at the end of life and
I'm like does he mean comedy everything
wraps back around a comedy right right
Oh dusty slave thanks for being on hot
breath man yeah thank you yeah great
time we're having a good time having a
good time appreciate you man yeah again
let's put her there yeah this is great
yeah I loved it move my legs around they
kept falling asleep that's what I was
doing I can't join like this and I'm
just I finna Ross in my arms and leaning
back and I'm just look pretty
uncomfortable yeah but both legs kept
falling asleep yeah oh well
[Music]